country superstar toby keith has
revealed he's been diagnosed with
stomach cancer sharing the news with his
fans on social media along with an
update about his treatment
yeah toby writes
last fall i was diagnosed with stomach
cancer i spent the last six months
receiving chemo radiation and surgery so
far so good i need time to breathe
recover and relax i am looking forward
to spending this time with my family but
i will see the fans sooner than later i
can't wait oh now toby didn't share any
further details about his diagnosis
and he was flooded with love and support
from the world of country music and
beyond in the comments
and toby has always been an advocate for
cancer research in 2006 he set up the
toby keith foundation which provides
no-cost housing for children with cancer
yeah i know his fans are very eager for
him to get back but of course we we all
know people who have
battled cancer it's really about taking
care of yourself having a point to look
forward to and to work for but to take
care of himself for sure it's super sad
and i think i think he just needs that
time to relax kind of like you just
mentioned and he said you just need to
take your time everything else can wait
the most important thing is your health
yeah so i think his blessings for sure
count your blessings and take all the
time you need
because it's different for everybody
yeah no absolutely we'll be excited when
he comes back for sure absolutely